[Music]
architecture from it's very beginning
has been made of stone and when it
hasn't been made of stone it's been made
to look like it's made of stone windows
may have glass in them but windows in a
stone wall or simply openings the glass
itself is not important the development
of technologies that allow the
production of large sheets of glass and
the materials with tensile strength like
steel had the power to enormous ly
change the way buildings are made but
how would that necessarily affect
architecture how would that change
architectures representational function
how would that change architecture as
the art of building the advances in
modern technology and the invention of
new materials were not an inevitable
helpful contributor to the goals of
architecture culture
how can one apply a symbolic language an
already existing symbolic architectural
language that was developed over
thousands of years as an expression of
the heavy compressive forces in masonry
to lightweight and thin structures of
metal and glass how does one achieve the
requisite monumentality and profundity
with such flimsy materials this was the
primary problem for the architects of
the 20th century